nous ne sommes pas dans le tennessee ou
sur la côte ouest mais dans les rues de
meudon au guidon du chopper renault
l'étoile de la zone il ne connaît pas
l'anglais il parle largo le verlan il
manie l'expression populaire avec
maestria et tout un public le comprend
après les années difficiles où il fut
magasinier plongeurs représentant
liftier tout en continuant à gratter la
guitare
le voici aujourd'hui sur le podium des
hit parades mais c'est toujours dans la
même barak qu'il répète avec ses copains
et au flipper type est entré dans le bar
a commandé un jambon-beurre physique
s'est approché de moi puis margarit
comme ça à les doigts devant potel
chabot
je parie c'est l'essentiel bien faire un
tour dans terrain vague tu vas prendre
un jeu rigolo à grands coups de chaînes
de vélo je te fais tes bottes à la
baston prescrits
laisse béton les jeunes surtout les
jeunes des milieux urbains se
reconnaissent en connaissent leur
langage et leur préoccupation
les faits divers que chantent ils sont
tous vécu ce que chante plus ou moins et
ils le ressentent bien parce que je
pense le l'exprimer dans leur langage
le samedi soir les gens la maison des
jeunes en banlieue ils vont s'éclater à
paris dans une boîte de nuit
alors il ya personne dans les maisons de
jeunes il me semble les bistrots c'est
ma seconde maison les 10 euros c'est le
lieu de communication
privilégié pour les jeunes vers ans
c'est là tout se passe quand on sait là
qu'on se construit le monde contre
détruit qu'on leur fait qu'on rêve qu'on
s'exprime
comment font-ils les autres jeunes pour
s'en sortir ceux qui ne sont pas
chanteur ou champions de football
le demande ils font ils font les
conneries qui meublent les pages des
faits divers des journaux ni vol bras
qui se battent s'ennuie 6 feuilles et
ils ont dit strauss
malgré les impératifs du show-business
renault il reviendra toujours dans ces
bistrots ne serait ce que pour chanter
boris vian on n'est pas là pour se faire
piétiner